first up we have a story on talking
monkeys why can't monkeys talk what
would they say if they could and most
importantly what would they sound like
Dave did you haven't imagined monkey
voice in your head you know before
hearing the clip that were about to play
I guess maybe ceaser from planet of the
apes although I know he's not a monkey
he is a chimpanzee so something like
that something a little a little deep a
little a little guttural maybe uh you
know I had that the monkey Butler voice
in my head are pretty sure much about
smooth British monkey Oh interesting
okay yeah um okay so now I'm gonna play
the clip that's what it sounds like have
you heard it yes um so your idea of what
a monkey voice sounded like it wasn't
creepy beyond the grave type marriage
proposal like we just heard why does
this sound the way it does where did the
research team come up with this voice
well this you know this all goes back to
this question of why can't our closest
primate relatives chimpanzees bonobos
even monkeys why can't they talk and for
a long time scientists have thought well
maybe they just don't have the right
vocal anatomy to talk maybe their vocal
cords aren't arranged in the right way
or whatever but that isn't is not very a
very satisfying explanation especially
when you consider that like animals like
parrots and elephants can make noise is
actually very similar to human speech
and they have a radically different
Anatomy than we do and that a lot of our
primate relatives do so the alternate
explanation is that their brains aren't
controlling their physiology the way our
brains control our physiology right and
the researchers try to figure out which
was the case right they turn to a
long-tailed macaque named Amelie on oh
and they didn't ask him to talk but what
they did do is they had him sort of sit
in the chair and they asked me to do a
bunch of different things like eat jaan
make a variety of vocalizations and lip
smacks and while he was doing this they
shot x-ray video of him and then what
they did with this x-ray video is they
actually used it to reconstruct his
vocal Anatomy how he created San
nouns and then they fed this into a
computer program and they basically have
this computer program say the audio that
you just played will you marry me and
based on that they concluded that yes
monkeys theoretically could talk like
people right and I listened to the human
version of this so they did something
similar with people you know play it
what do you marry me it doesn't sound
much different so this isn't really you
know monkeys sound like you know ghostly
voices it's just this is the best a
computer simulation can do with those
components exactly and you know
fundamentally what it's showing in the
very least you know we can argue with
the quality of the recording but it
shows that at least monkeys could
theoretically produce these types of
sounds and it you know if we heard them
we would be able to sort of understand
what they were saying
[Music]